In December 2018, for the first time,
teacher strikes ensnared a charter
school network. This was seen by many as
another sign that unions are coming for
charter schools.
Indeed, unions have worked avidly to
organize more charter school teachers.
Are they succeeding? Nope!
During the past decade, the share of
unionized charters has actually declined.
What's the story? Well, it's tough for
unions to organize charter teachers when
union leaders are busy treating charter
schools as a political pinata, and a
target during teacher strikes and
legislative fights. It's also not clear
that unions think charters are ultimately
worth the trouble!
Charter schools tend to be small, account
for just a tiny fraction of all teachers,
and typically require unions to work
school-by-school, rather than by
organizing whole school districts at a
time. Charters have much to offer
teachers frustrated by district
bureaucracies, but this has been too
rarely celebrated  — or communicated — by
advocates. Whatever the unions do, that's
one place charters need to do much
better.
Do you think it's good or bad for
charter schools to be unionized? Let us
know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.